foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
actual break room here in Los Angeles
California we're thrilled to be here
with you uh I've got with me uh Brandon
bear hello sorry we're a little late
they're doing construction outside yes
they've got the power this is for you
and your and your headphones wearing uh
safety okay that you don't hear a
jackhammer not banging it ain't us
unfortunately I've also got uh Angelica
Trey sorry that was me doing
construction outside
is my cool new Jackhammer oh very cool
you should see your put up drywall it's
incredible yeah and then Tom
Michaelson's here oh and then I was
actually holding the Angelica's lemonade
watching her being like ready for a
refill just topping it off yeah
climate change it takes a village
today on uh uh the break room first off
there is a siren in the background they
are coming here
um we've got we've got some She-Hulk
Cameo news leaks whatever uh we've got
some Batman news some Aquaman too a lot
of DC news a little bit of Wonder Woman
news
um there's a lot going on today we also
have a really fun Redemption
um Marvel did a fun thing on Twitter
where uh you know in the last episode of
She-Hulk Emil Blonsky in prison uh
mentioned that you've been writing
poetry he has all these soul mates out
there in the world seven seven soul
Maine that's right uh seven is a perfect
number of syllables okay because they
mentioned that give at a certain number
of retweets they would
um start publishing his haikus not his
tonkas his haikus what's a Tonka a Tonka
is uh because the haiku's three lines I
believe a Tonka is five lines
Chrissy Chrissy in the chat let us
confirm
we might have uh one of those uh haikos
that they released that we can pull up
but uh we again through our Insider
access we are shills for Disney and in
return they feed us little bits we they
sent us in a sealed manual envelope
unreleased Emil Blonsky hikes right
that's right that's true
um some of these are dirty oh some of
these are they spent some time behind
them with a woman you gotta put some
time they're nice dirty though yeah yeah
the nice guy polite yeah
at 100 intervals we will uh release one
of these Emile Blonsky Haiku yeah yeah
exclusive there's no other way to get
these okay these are going to be on like
a DVD and these are haikus these are not
tatankas no which of course
um so uh again we appreciate everybody
in the chat uh and folks throwing us a
couple of doubloons in the Super Chat
always appreciate that oh Gregor already
uh threw a couple bucks in their trash
bag Tuesday my man okay
um all the Baggers in the chat uh that's
a new one tea bags
I feel like tea bag was like a fun
secret thing and then once like
mainstream starts reporting on two bags
tea bagging maybe never fun as well
protection assault predatory yeah
predatory again not these not these
haikus okay
um
uh Boogie's world thank you sir or Madam
whoever Boogie is ah oh but first we got
some good headlines to get to headlines
set out yeah we've got a bunch you know
what we've been getting so many DC and
DC EU headlines lately yep not a lot of
them great we actually have some
quasi-positive ones today that we're
excited about
um well okay the first one is
last week
is that people getting fired at movies
getting thrown in the garbage or
anything like that okay though this
first one is negative
we're gonna work our way up
anti-positive anti-positive that's right
uh so this Variety article came out
again there's been a lot of kind of like
uh post-mortems of all this drama coming
out of Warner Brothers Discovery and
this Variety article came out it said
that most or many Warner Brothers
Executives hated release things exciters
Justice League they regret doing it they
think it never should have happened they
shouldn't have uh kowtowed to the
release the Snyder cut campaign now
it kind of makes intuitive sense
obviously if they were all big fans of
the starter cut you wouldn't have needed
a fan campaign to get them to put it out
right
and now here they are like I mean I
understand the the logic behind it
though because you know if you if you
cave in that sense what they think
you're doing is caving to them now
you're gonna you've just created this
monster right yeah I think they're in a
tough position too because around that
time uh the news about Joss Whedon
started coming out Zack Snyder was kind
of on a positive new swing and they got
a ton of PR and marketing free marketing
out of like re-releasing a movie that
didn't perform as well as they would
have liked or it did well for DC but it
they thought it would do better they got
a lot of new they got a lot of granite
they were still kind of promoting HBO
Max that was something
during the pandemic they didn't have a
lot of films to put out it kind of made
like 40 million right doing all the
research it's 70 but it was a lot of a
lot of money and as we've learned from
this merger right uh there was a lot of
debt with uh HBO Max and Warner Brothers
that uh Discovery kind of took on as
part of this that's why they're cutting
a lot of projects and stuff so I mean
very easy to look back and say like we
should have never done it but at the
time I'm sure they were all clinking
glasses like yes we got 10 million
streams of this yeah think of the
hashtag yeah I could see like one side
it divided the you know fan base or
whatever but then the other side is it
drove a lot of people to subscribe to
HBO Max so pick your poison and all
those people voted in the Oscars to make
flashes entering the speed force the
number one moment of Our Lives same
number that scene is the same number of
oscars as Martin's course aging okay uh
but also what we were just gonna say a
takeaway from that I mean if there was
any speculation like the entire standard
first thing is dead right if they were
great doing that we're not getting any
more Justice League films we're probably
not going to get after the ones that are
already in production are going to be
released we're probably not going to get
any more Flash and there's all this will
they won't they with Henry Cavill being
Superman still like every day I feel
like I hear nope definitely not and the
next day it's like actually they're
talking about it and it's gonna it's
gonna come out guys and yeah I feel like
the whole place is on fire over there I
don't think they know what's gonna
happen absolutely absolutely yeah they
they don't know what to do outside
that's a construction happening they're
building the building's going down right
now
we figured it out yeah but they're just
having regrets now retroactively with
Snyder cut yes now moving on to again
um less anti-positives
moving up Jason Momoa out there talking
about uh Aquaman 2 even though we're
he loves that movie and he and he wants
to talk about it he's teasing maybe
multiple Batman characters might be
appearing now again it's kind of a vague
quote he's like oh yeah better like
might be in it and and like maybe
there's even more Batman's in it who
knows now that could be just him kind of
teasing and doing a bit because we know
Michael Keaton showing up in the flash
was supposed to show up in Batgirl right
um maybe there's even more I mean and
there was all this word of like reshoots
with Ben Affleck yeah Batman and new
things well there there's there's kind
of three Batman active right now right
here
I was about to say I would love to see
like bats like just randomly show up in
scenes and then Robert Pattinson
battenson is like walking slowly up in
every scene the motion flooded
how are you like walk so slow
and any move so cryptically
it could even be like The Imaginarium of
Dr Parnassus kind of thing where it's
like what if what if they're not yeah
they're playing the exact same Batman
it's just the actor changes and they
never explain it right I'm hoping that
they're going to redo no way home and
there's gonna be Keaton's gonna land on
the Statue of Liberty first then they're
gonna bat that glad and then at the
centers
uh he's actually holding the camera
probably but he's there he's directing
yeah so I mean that that's fun and hey
way to get us talking Jason Momoa uh
keep doing your thing
um speaking of another DC film that's
not coming out until next year Shazam
two uh Devin first Pharisee apologies
Devin I'm butchering your name uh
reporting uh gal gadot's Wonder Woman is
going to be in this film that has not
been in any trailer yet but I think it
had already been teased earlier uh and
now he's he kind of followed up I think
he had dropped that scoop before and I
was following up they're like oh she's
actually you're going to have a
substantial role in this film including
like a big action sequence so uh Wonder
Woman gonna be playing maybe a an
important role in Shazam 2 Fury of the
Gods sure yeah I mean maybe maybe gal
gadot's last appearance as Wonder Woman
well supposedly they're doing this
Wonder Woman three oh no one over three
how did Jenkins out in London making a
movie reclaim but it makes sense oh no I
was I just think she's such a great
Wonder Woman you know I feel like he'll
keep her around so I was speaking with
you know with the Shazam verse like
about it being with the gods and Zeus
and stuff yeah it has to tie into Diana
and Wonder Woman and yeah it seems like
a logical step and maybe you know Shazam
will go seek her out as help you know to
come fight these Gods because she
doesn't know he doesn't know what he's
doing who knows but it makes sense in
terms of crossovers Let's Do It
um pivoting to some MCU news uh in an
exclusive interview with the direct uh
panel of gorse uh She-Hulk attorney at
law head writer and producer Jessica GAO
comment on where the show Falls and the
MCU timeline and this is something we've
kind of speculated on a bunch back and
forth uh she confirmed that She-Hulk is
after post endgame
after post endgame now that is both a
specific answer and complete
gobbledygoop like just talking and it's
a weird like after posting game you know
far from home takes place post end game
and this is after yeah that's well
beyond it yeah yeah she's probably
trying to distance it from that very
very far beyond pregame too far you
can't even remember
well and and one of the interesting
things that came out of this interview
was she kind of confirmed that there was
a person that works at Marvel who is the
official MCU timeline keeper or
timekeeper I think was the exact
phrasing which I love that I want that
job yeah or please let's interview that
person or it's incredibly stressful
right because you're uh so where were
you when when homecoming came out and it
said eight years they screwed up the
whole time yeah exactly yeah
homecoming yeah maybe this is my first
time
um
phrasing she's using after post endgame
is actually specific maybe like there's
a white board somewhere in the Marvel
offices that's like post endgame was a
specific block of yeah yeah and then
after post is after that right they
don't have a better name more shots of
calendars than the NC yes more shots of
newspaper headline please janitors at
Marvel uh tweet us let's take some
photos and tweet us just like BC and uh
A.D we're gonna say AP after posts
um oh this is a fascinating story that I
don't think like we've ever heard any
leak of this even though the news is
almost 15 years old
um Neil Gaiman went on the happy side
confused podcast and revealed that he
and Guillermo del Toro had worked on a
pitch for a doctor strange film back in
2007. well they start yeah they started
like talking with Kevin feige in 2007
yeah
but on the time when they're building
that you know yeah they're like playing
together what a team the guy spent years
like putting together this like
idea for a movie Yes before like I mean
not only before Scott Derrickson started
working on the doctor strange right
first film but like yeah before like the
first Avengers film before anything was
in place which is wild also like yeah
just those two talents together yeah
that's gonna be a cool movie even take
out the Marvel part of it right why
haven't those guys worked again wild
yeah yeah like a fantasy sci-fi Guru and
like the Macabre oh my God I mean after
watching Sandman like can you imagine
something enough to like you know
they've really done a real Multiverse of
Madness I think that was one of the
things I missed from that movie it's
like you got only one other the 838
Multiverse we didn't really go much
places other than that one Montage true
yeah if they could do something way
nicer those guys can do it yeah but who
would say way nutser I said waynet
[Music]
he mentioned a couple parts of their
pitch and maybe it kind of explains why
they didn't go this route but like
Doctor Strange was an alcoholic and a
disbarred physician who'd been around
since the 1920s
yeah that that might be a bit out there
for for phase one Marvel yeah yeah well
and it kind of bites into both some of
what they want to do with Tony Stark
being maybe the alcohol thing and then
1920s like that's a little bit you're
biting into uh Captain America right the
president nice thing and those were
clearly gonna be two of their kind of
tent poles for phase one so maybe that's
yeah yeah it's like it was like a man
out of time kind of story yeah like he'd
been around since like the 20s and
there's just living in New York it was
like New York changed around him but
they already did that in a little show
called New Amsterdam
I feel like they established that uh
Doctor Strange was you know dejected for
so long with the sweatpants just fine
you know like they did it perfectly yeah
beard Scruff sweatpants like jacket
casual clothing and and we all
understood when we saw that yeah
absolutely that's a cry for help
yeah I Cry for Help
um there's a little bit of other
She-Hulk news now I just want to say
if you hate spoilers for the next
episode of She-Hulk just muteus for like
two minutes okay don't leave how dare
you even think about leaving or closing
this video this is a little bit of a
spoiler though it was not it it was kind
of published it's out there
um and this has been rumored for a while
but uh according to a piece in the cut
Megan the stallion has officially been
cast in She-Hulk she's gonna play like
kind of a heightened version of herself
or a version of a kind of a pop star
along the lines of Megan the stallion
um in several episodes I think is what I
think we know for sure she's in the next
episode uh coming out uh tomorrow
evening at midnight but we don't know I
don't know if she comes back anymore
after that we don't know yeah we don't
know maybe would you get her once get
her twice at least we'll know after that
episode I feel like well now you'll feel
it you'll be like okay she's gonna
return yeah okay let's hope let's hope
she's like hey come to my concert in
three episodes there you go I'm a little
angry like at the cut of doing this this
is stuff like variety loves to do though
I'm just spoil things because they think
us a little nerds don't deserve to have
any fun like who cares about this show
and I get that this is a way to get
people to tune into the show but like
you could have waited or yeah tell us
this six months ago when we're getting
trailers or put her in the trailer right
yeah when did they announce like
Thundercat for Boca Boba Fett did they
announce that or was it that was a
surprise yeah I don't know I'm surprised
okay
and one good idea Megan the stallion is
a much bigger get than ThunderCats
you're listening please on your way to
the studio pick up Thundercats come on
come on
um uh okay and then uh end spoilers
thank you John
um okay back back to now this is not a
spoiler because this thing's not coming
out for like over a year but uh Ben
Kingsley it was announced in I think
variety today is gonna reprise his role
as Trevor Slattery in the upcoming
Wonder Man series it's going to be on
Disney plus
um who would have guessed that like
Trevor Slattery and Wong are gonna have
like the most appearances in the MCU at
the end of the day uh very cool the
little bit we know about the winter Man
series being produced by Sean Chi
director
Dustin Daniel [ __ ] yeah however you
pronounced last name
um and you know the Wonder main
character often is like kind of like
tied up in Hollywood he's like you know
he's a movie star kind of thing so it
kind of makes sense because Trevor
Slattery is an actor right and was in
was in the Sean Chi movie of course so
like uh great we also know uh Brandon
who else is gonna be in well there's a
rumor that like Ralph boner might show
up who had head showers that's right and
of course you have the Asgardian actors
yeah
Sam Neal yeah
oh my God boner could poke his head out
yeah I'm hoping still uh I don't know if
this is just a fan cast or what but
Nathan Fillion as wonder man I've that
he would be a freaking hilarious wow
heard that but maybe it was a fan cast
type situation
no offense come on the show Nathan
defend yourself
uh folks uh throwing some super chats
out there thank you uh geek Ledger d23
let's go the marvelous weekend is coming
yes in fact we're just about to talk
about d23 news here in a moment uh David
Henry Bennett thank you uh Connor Lauren
Wagner
uh Hey schedule aligned us to watch live
from the start hell yeah good to have
you here Connor Lauren
um so Sam something uh anyone else think
Damon from House of the Dragons looks
like Zach possible cosplay
give me a platinum wig hey
um Matt Smith is a handsome gentleman
yeah I take that as a high compliment uh
thank you I've seen Matt Smith in person
we got to go to the house of the Dragon
Premiere
yeah
nice to meet you I can't tell what was
your impression Brandon just real quick
I love The Spectator on celebrities
Heights
um he uh oh got a technical issue here
Tom's gonna pop out
um he Matt Smith appeared to be one of
the tallest people there but I can't
tell if that's because he's a legit or
beginning we were sitting and he was
standing and most people were standing
or was everybody there five seven and
under and it was a little bit that we
weren't below he was standing it was the
premiere for The House of the drafts of
the Dragon the Lord of the Rings they
showed like the first episode Game of
Thrones show that he's on yeah
yeah okay okay
um yeah I was trying to think
like probably everyone's maybe shorter
he was wearing like a tight suit was he
wearing tall shoes he could have been in
lifts yeah yeah he also came out from
the ceiling they lowered him down he did
really yeah yeah he kept uh screaming
it's morbid time he kept streaming it
and then they show you know the show the
episode during the scene where he's
having sex with his mistress yeah he
went get it back
get it boy which I thought was awkward
but quiet theater and he yelled that it
was weird it was weird
um
show it again you made him he made him
replay it like Tommy does with the
mandatory fun grab yeah yeah that's my
smell hey man break that come on the
show come on this show tell that story
person hey it's a race to the Finish
Line who'll be on the show first
Chrissy says Matt is like six feet tall
Chrissy has said nothing but facts in
the chat her whole life and this is a
like like six feet tall like six feet
tall could be five nine yeah it could be
what Google says don't tell me what
Google says it's all a lie yeah gotta
take measure and go go I don't know why
I assume everyone on camera is like
short like you're like my height short
you know cameras cannot go above five
feet yeah they are not allowed to go any
higher it gets complicated too if you
have a short person a tall person
they're in the same they put them on
apple boxes yeah exactly so it's all
that Hollywood magic we're all the same
height too so yeah
a legit tall person in Hollywood they
often look like a giant like James Bond
is like legitimately like six four or
something like that and that's why he
Tower you make everyone the same size on
Jeopardy that's my favorite thing yeah
oh do they give people boxes behind the
podium so they're all the same size and
all people are smart they don't even try
with Will Ferrell I feel like he's
always just punched over everybody
speaking of equally smart uh Brandon why
don't we jump into this next segment
okay I'm going to introduce it here I'll
introduce it while you set it up okay
um so next week is a big week for Disney
uh next Thursday they're gonna have
Disney plus day where we're anticipating
we're gonna get some announcements some
dates for a lot of this series that we
haven't yet gotten announcements for and
then next weekend there's going to be a
bunch of panels at d23 including some
big Marvel panels and we're thinking
this is gonna be
um like an extended version of that
Comic-Con uh Marvel panel where going to
get more releases maybe a couple more
casting announcements right they told us
so much but there's still a lot of holes
left in what they told us at Comic-Con
uh
take it from here Brandon okay so we
know we have Disney plus day right and
we're expecting some things to get
announced on that day we're probably
gonna get like maybe a secret Invasion
trailer let's hope because that's like
an upcoming series coming very soon or
something like maybe like some footage
yeah
Loki season two possibly yeah yeah yeah
ironheart is shooting right now so it
could be like they could put out some
footage from that this is all based on
like what we've seen in the past right
they've put out like little trailers
before yeah a little sneak things let's
go some more I don't know what else is
on the list yes sir oh it's okay uh
werewolf by night oh I mean the thing
nobody knows anything about that's being
directed by a composer we keep assuming
it's coming out this Halloween season
yeah which is like five weeks away and
they we've seen Funko Pops for Guardians
of the Galaxy holiday special we don't
know anything about werewolf and some
set photos but uh yeah so if you don't
know werewolf by Nightwolf uh but
various why did you Mumble the werewolf
because werewolf okay
I'm liking this description
he's not a mixture of algae and mold so
he's not really a liking okay get yours
back straight uh thank you John big big
arborist in the back John Costa ladies
and gentlemen uh uh he's a well he's
like attached to kind of the Moon night
and when they were doing those QR codes
on moon night one of them was like a
werewolf by night yes Moon Knight first
appeared I don't wear off by night
anyways but we're hoping we get werewolf
finite news but otherwise it's been
radio silent and like an armor Wars
release date remember that you promised
us that show uh but we've also heard
like they're supposedly making a koye
show produced by Ryan coogler uh a 10
Ring show I think he's gonna focus on
like the sister or forget her name
apologies to ten Rings uh Nova
uh and then like season two of moon
night we could hear about that even this
aforementioned wonder man that we were
just talking about they just leaked out
some some casting uh yeah which is a
good point that we might hear more about
that so let's look at to the board
what about the day the days that follow
we're gonna learn more about face okay
and so uh Brandon's done a great job
putting together this one down so now
this is this is phase six we're ignoring
that short for you we are ignoring phase
five
are you okay uh most of Kevin got Apple
Bot
uh I'm only six nine I don't know a
Samsung box whatever kind of phone you
use yeah uh so Kevin feige most of his
Comic-Con panel was spent on phase five
right like filling in the the Agatha
Harkness series
um you know a lot of the low-key season
two yeah a lot of those things we know
when those are coming out in 2023 right
right uh in early 2024 but then he kind
of blew all of our minds when he also
announced phase six with these three
tent pole films Fantastic Four Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars but he gave us
nothing else in phase six yeah and like
phase five kind of ended with our uh
Thunderbolts I believe
and then we come into here there's like
there was like this empty fall spot
right uh and then we uh we know
Fantastic Four is coming out November
8th 2024 we know Kang Dynasty and we
know Secret Wars now there was like
another piece to this that came out this
week A lot of times uh the studios they
send dates to movie theater chains to be
like hey we're gonna have movies coming
out these days we're not gonna tell you
what the movies are yet but just get
ready hold this spot for this spot for
us yeah and it's also like a threat to
other Studios don't release your big
movie this weekend don't you dare so
dates that got added this winter 2025
spot of February 14 2025 came out so
that's probably gonna be a movie yes and
we were were thinking like maybe
Deadpool 3 could go there yeah I like
that yeah maybe yeah we also learned
about like one of these summer 2025s in
between these two big Avengers movies uh
is gonna be a movie that comes out July
thank you so much 25th 2025. so like
this is probably a show this is a movie
because this is only uh less than six
months yeah or about six months yeah and
we were saying this feels a lot like
Infinity war and end game yeah which if
you remember Ant-Man and the WASP came
out in between those two films and
Captain Marvel and Captain Marvel they
had a whole year yeah they were far
they're spread out apart so maybe just
one film coming out of two of these and
so we're gonna speculate on what so we
feel like again based on this is a
calendar year Marvel has been kind of
aiming for four theatrical releases per
calendar year ish yeah right so um we
know three of these actually sorry this
little over counter year and this is
five slots yeah for films right they're
kind of ramping up so we're gonna
speculate on what these two other films
are and then we are going to start
placing some of the what we think are
Disney plus Series in between the
theatrical releases kind of like this
year what we got kind of uh no way home
and then we got Multiverse of Madness
and then we got Thor 11 Thunder and then
we got uh we will get wakanda forever
right right yeah
do you have any thoughts on a movie we
were saying we love Deadpool 3 here
right because it's it's been talked
about the longest we know it's being
written it's definitely development a
lot more than some of these other
projects yeah I mean Fantastic Four to
be fair is maybe has a director
we're not even there yet yeah like it's
probably sure we might get we might get
a casting announcement at d23 yeah yeah
they're probably doing the previous they
probably have most of the effects done
for the final fight yeah uh they just
need to put a case on some of the
characters yeah they're probably only
also pissed that most of the characters
don't wear a mask in the Fantastic Four
oh my God we need their faces uh great
reason to have Dr Doom is the villain
there you go there you go so we feel the
best because of all the films that are
still kind of available that have been
mentioned in some way this feels like it
might be the furthest along in the
development process
um with one exception
we know deadline has reported there is a
movie Somewhere in development called
the mutant yes right now Deadpool is a
mutant okay yes uh depending on how they
want to treat it yeah
um so I was kind of saying this might
make sense here now Tom you had a good
reason why the mutants might make sense
here or here yeah I was thinking like
you know kind of like how with infinity
war and end game when they introduced
Captain Marvel to bring her into the
second movie they primed her with her
own movie first before end game so I was
thinking you know the secret Wars would
be a great place to bring everybody
together and if we don't have the
mutants by then we don't have the X-Men
by that time it'll be very I I find it
very hard to figure where we would put
them in otherwise because that because
you could also make an X-Men story a
smaller story it doesn't have to be this
huge Galactic well that's not it's not
the X-Men it's the moon that's true
I do like the idea if there is like an
incursion going on which causes the
secret Wars if our mutants come from
like another timeline where their world
is gone yeah like we need a home we're
coming here yeah that's like a perfect
yeah like combo is one of us so she's
like whoa I just got this time
I don't know you and I think I love that
logic though I will say the total
opposite could also be true because as
much as they kind of carefully placed
Captain Marvel to set her up to appear
in this in end game also Ant-Man and the
WASP though you know it kind of set up
the van with the rat and blah blah blah
but for the most part that movie had no
impact on either the idea of time travel
through the quantum very important yeah
yeah yeah yeah but it was also it was
kind of like a non-sequitur film right
like it was set before the events of
infinity War except for that movie
without Infinity Awards
say if they wanted some counter
programming here right they're telling
this Big multi-film Arc so they don't
want to further complicate that with
another film in the storyline maybe that
could make sense for a Shang Chi sequel
right let's head over here let's ever
head over to Tallow or whatever right
yeah or now we're we're speculating
again this has there is nothing in this
currency about that this is just fan
speculation because we know we're
getting a blade movie and you know Moon
Knight exists in The Ether werewolf By
Night Ghost Riders got to show up
eventually we get yeah so maybe we get
Midnight tons now when we do we don't
know if it'll be a series or a film
but maybe if it's a film maybe that
makes sense right there because this is
like totally different right it's kind
of street level and Hell level and all
that kind of jazz yeah demons and yeah
it's like totally unrelated kind of I
can see right I could see that too you
kind of do its own Standalone type thing
well I I feel like that type of thing
would be
you think that would be summer
oh yeah does it feel like a good summer
movies
okay I think we're rolling with mutants
one one argument here is good old
eternals too okay the movie everybody is
clamoring one's for you my guy okay
listen the other the other flip of the
coin of the movie in between the big
ones is Captain Marvel and it's setting
up the nuke right you gotta set up the
powerful weapon right you gotta deal
with like multiverses and a gang and all
that you might need a Celestial on your
side okay the eternals two go and like
rope themselves a Celestial and dragon
not necessarily on the good side of
celestronauts
but they've learned that lesson they've
come around some of them are dead you
know let's let's let them have their
chance to come back yes all right now
Harry Styles does not seem interested in
doing a movie so we'll see wait who said
he's not interested he kind of said he's
into music right now okay yeah but this
is 2025
okay he'll finish his tour he'll do what
is going to be a very exciting don't
worry baby press tour okay and it's got
a few more marriages to ruin folks okay
shots fired guys we're gonna come on the
show Harry foreign
the two exceptions we make on this show
about things we talk about are the
Barbie film and don't worry baby okay
we're gonna and don't worry maybe it
might even be sci-fi so that might kind
of
don't worry darling
yeah first I'm gonna get the name of the
movie right second we're gonna talk
about it on this show okay now let's
just say I like both these two options
let's just leave them both here for now
okay and now let's start feeling shows
give me some shout outs let's start
filling in with the shows now
um you had Brandon a great Point earlier
that
um
Dustin Daniel [ __ ] yeah who is
producing Wonder Man and directing uh
Kang Dynasty he's a busy guy yeah
yeah now they could pass that off to
someone else sure he could say I'm
producer right but I could see that
waiting until after yeah maybe that's a
phase seven kind of thing which we might
talk about to bring shangshi into like
some other story yeah she's might show
up in these films he doesn't need yet
another solo film I think he didn't get
the show done though about his sister
okay now before the movie yeah now
because we know more about wonder man
this is coming sooner earlier he's also
producing that so maybe this shows up
here yeah right because like you're
already you're already announcing cameos
two years ago yeah um and so then this
is probably going to be spaced out from
that because I think even if he's just
producing it Dustin Daniel there's only
so many hours in the day so maybe this
could be again counterpro Grandma yeah
maybe uh there
everyone's talking about like Young
Avengers right Young Avengers as a movie
I think they could do younger vendors as
like a show and I also like this I could
see that in between these big ones
because if you need the Young Avengers
to fight here you don't want to like
form them in this movie this is where we
disagree this is where we disagree too
much team up that's it okay
too many team-ups that's right I like
this kitchen I think this is gonna
happen but why not why not have my way
out here we already know okay Bishop's
out there we already know a lot of these
Ms Marvel a lot of these characters
they're always setting up for it too
yeah they've been setting up for it we
also we know they love to change titles
on us okay in at the end of phase five
like I said you have Thunderbolts I
could see Thunderbolts versus Young
Avengers is what that turns out to be
because we don't know where the
Thunderbolts are even gonna fight right
and I want them to be villainous put
them against like a good team make us
root for one or the other for real this
time right well and then that's fun
because you can see the Young Avengers
these Punk kids yeah people think
they're bad guys but they're actually
good guys Thunderbolts people think
they're good guys but they're actually
and they've wiped out a lot of our
regular Avengers they're off world or
they're dead and I love the idea of like
the government puts together the
Thunderbolts and there's no Avengers to
like stop them so these kids who are all
going to be in their 30s by the time
this comes out yeah they decide like hey
it's up to us the Next Generation yeah
a couple things we wanted to talk about
here
um things that we know have been
announced to some degree or another yeah
we know Ryan coogler is working on an
Okoye show we know somebody is working
on a Nova series or project we don't
know it could be a film still but I was
saying we're getting wakanda Forever at
the end of 2022. okay nothing else has
been announced set in the world of
wakanda black panther whatever so like
we're not going to go that many years
without yeah visiting that place so I
think this is a pretty good guarantee to
be happening in phase six and I think
that's a good place for spring yeah for
like uh not the big summer 10 polls you
know like a spring or a winter or yeah
window of release here yeah okay I can
dig it and then we we're all talking
about Miss Marvel season two right they
seem like with Echo with Loki season two
like they're ready to pump out yeah
second seasons of these shows right are
you like do you think like summer just
the next year right yeah
but we assume they're gonna like add it
yes and now I personally I don't know if
anybody else in the audience I'm
personally always getting confused
between ironheart and armor Wars because
they both sound similar titles they're
kind of set in the tangential Tony Stark
kind of people wearing Heroes people
wearing Mech suits kind of world so like
maybe it's still in development but they
wanted to space it out a little bit from
Iron I still think it's coming out
before all this yeah
this would be out before like an iron
heart but I've we've heard about
ironheart filming yeah I haven't heard
anything about armor put it in the
corner put it in the corner yeah nobody
puts baby in the corner nobody puts
don't worry baby in the corner also I'll
just say if we see the trailer for
secret Invasion and it heavily features
Don Cheadle I don't think is happening
then that gives us our Roadie fix and we
don't need him to have his own Series
yeah
um okay a couple other things yeah again
midnight sons has not really been talked
about at all uh Scarlett Johansson
apparently has a deal to produce a film
for Marvel produce so this doesn't mean
another Black Widow film right could be
whatever we don't know
um we know no other details people have
been talking a lot about World War Hulk
lately because of that whole sakar ship
and he's going off world we've never
gotten a Ruffalo Standalone Hulk movie
yeah but there's also Spider-Man 4 which
Disney is not going to get to a Disney
Marvel they're not going to get to
announce the date and they it wouldn't
be one of the the dates they gave to a
theater because that's up for Sony to do
but they'll probably leave space for it
right and you got to imagine that Sony
wants this out before this yeah
especially if Spider-Man's involved with
like Secret Wars at King Dynasty at all
definitely before this so maybe you know
they love to drop a Spider-Man movie
Christmas time right this would be uh
three years after no way home if we kind
of to tentatively plug it here maybe you
know Fantastic Four November Spider-Man
4 December maybe maybe rumor has it
they'll bring in a fourth Spidey so
all of them
um okay other things again Moon Knight
two besides some kind of flirty uh
Instagram public confirm nothing
confirmed Dr Strange three and Thor five
are kind of in the same boat of like
Legacy characters these actors seem down
to make whatever movie they want but
nothing's been announced well here hang
on to these okay I'm hanging are you
saying the night's not confirmed for
season two yeah they're kind of acting
like it is like they're pretending
they're scouting locations
they were kind of like are we are we
well we do know that like in Phase seven
oh okay
here we go okay I'm ready guys when they
gave out those dates to other movies
this hap all happens after Secret Wars
they they call it a couple dates
February 13 2026 May 1st 2026 July 2026
and November 2026. okay is this where
you start seeing like Doctor Strange
three like four or five maybe Sean Chi
comes in like here with a sequel or
something like that yeah uh you could
have like weird movies like this showing
up I mean I don't I doubt they want to
wait this long to do Spider-Man 4 and
again this wouldn't be Disney's
announcement to me some of these
characters some of these characters in
like the current phases we've watched
like they've skipped their sequel
because they were featured in other
movies like yes like Captain Marvel you
know they had her own movie but then she
was in end game and then her true sequel
isn't coming out for what would be years
right after the first time so I can
imagine that with some of these videos
before wouldn't this be nuts if like we
go we expand the MCU so much Young
Avengers Thunderbolts all these
different characters and then we come
back in 2026 is the year of the OG's
here and we go back to Doctor Strange
Thor and Hulk right that's possible and
maybe even like I mean by this point
right like we could be getting sequels
to 2023 movies yeah yeah
you start getting like something like I
know Xiang Chi was 20 20 21 but like
yeah you could get another Captain
America movie in that space right yeah
we know we're gonna get Captain America
New World Order in Phase five so I don't
know
I don't know this is also there's the
rumor that this is like the mutant phase
if the mutants come around
yeah you just have like a ton of like
mutant movies and some other stuff all
four of these could be Wolverine solo
films
um okay let's give me some Wolverine so
uh thank you Brandon for putting that
all together again yeah we're hoping we
get all this information next week
um tease us Kevin feige give us
something to react it looks like a
morsel yes
on the break room we'll be talking on
d23 day of course we'll be kind of
reporting live and then we're gonna have
a show that Saturday uh I'm sorry we'll
be talking on Thursday about Disney plus
day and then that Saturday we'll be
reporting live during these panels at
d23 uh dropping those new dropping that
news reacting uh we got a couple super
chats we want to uh shout out uh
teach apologies I'm sorry I butcher your
name Angelica Trey yes shouting you out
John Dunham
um uh saying what if they're saving the
first official F-bomb for Deadpool
um yeah we have not had enough Harmony
yeah
everybody will join them first two
seconds of the movie too just to get it
out yeah yeah you can say one I think in
a PGA PG-13 forget one you say one you
can say yeah yeah yeah
um okay cool uh well again that was a
lot of speculation but we feel pretty
good about some of those hold us to it
we'll revisit yeah these boards yeah
revisit it please do yeah we do feel
good about what we did here and we all
want to feel good out there we want to
do good things be good people try and
save the environment we try and do that
but it's hard to do right but what if I
told you that you could tackle your
negative impact on our climate just by
using a credit card once a day I'd like
to introduce you to the concept of the
aspiration zero credit card okay we're
all trying to make better decisions
every day to help the planet but
switching to using an aspiration zero
credit card can crush your negative
carbon footprint just by using it for
everyday purchases aspiration zero is
the first credit card that fights
climate change by planting trees with
every swipe trees planted boom wow with
an aspiration zero credit card you plant
two trees with every purchase you make
and two trees soak up about the same
amount of carbon dioxide from the air as
the average American puts out every day
plus it's the minimum number of trees
you need for a hammock okay and along
with the reward of knowing that you've
turned buying some some new figurines
into a way to do your part to save the
planet you get the other kind of green
reward too
oh unlimited one percent cash back on
all of your monthly purchases when you
hit carbon zero for the month thanks to
people like you yes you aspirations made
a huge impact they've already planted 75
million trees and they will not be
stopped anti-tree conglomerates make
your dollars make a difference apply for
the aspiration zero credit card today
and earn a 300 welcome bonus after
spending three thousand dollars in the
first 90 days tell Paul Bunyan to shove
it quit cutting down my tree's Paul
we're planting more trees apply right
now at aspiration.com break room to go
carbon neutral effortlessly and earn a
300 bonus go to aspiration.com breakroom
the aspiration zero MasterCard is issued
by beneficial State Bank pursuance
license by MasterCard International
Incorporated good credit required terms
and conditions do apply hey guys thank
you thank you aspiration for helping us
bring the show to you
um real quick
um if Tommy bechtered here do you know
the kind of angry things he'd have to
say to you trash baggers for the fact
that we didn't do anything we have yet
to read now maybe the folks just don't
understand how great
um an Abomination Haiku is John did we
ever throw up the actual official
released Abomination haiku
yeah that'd be great can you put that on
the screen one of them yeah Marvel
released this if inside you feel a rage
uncontrollable just breathe Namaste
very chill very Zen yeah from the
reformed
it's okay okay
five seven five either
um here I'm just gonna you know that we
haven't hit a Redemption number I'm
gonna tease them with dances with one um
you're a young child
these are again Marvel Marvel released
these
um to us on the condition that we only
read them out loud
this is an official Emile Blonsky Haiku
that he wrote in prison on the She-Hulk
series okay
green is not so mean
Jennifer seems pretty nice
but [ __ ] Bruce he sucks
a few years before maybe speaking of and
yeah
and this is I mean this is pretty
Deadpool that's why they didn't put this
on the show
you write it down you don't act it out
that's right write it down you don't act
it up that's what that's all about uh oh
Brandon yeah I think we wanted to do a
little do we have time do we have time
for mandatory fun
play that graphic
yeah
okay okay we don't have time to do
multiple Graphics okay because we are
really play it again
oh yes okay I'm not doing it again
because I think Deadpool is right and
it's over you
I'm sick sick man all right so Eric's
video uh yesterday uh about She-Hulk it
kind of pointed out an interesting
moment in the second episode where a
Holden Holloway of gcal GLK slash H uh
he's talking about uh the kind of shady
Origins and like of or he's talking to
Jennifer and Jennifer's well she's
walking through the office
exploited and used what no get out of
here she's also talking
that's true but she's targeting direct
to camera right she's breaking the
fourth wall so she's not listening as
he's going on this kind of monologue
while they walk through the office and
then he turns to her at the end of the
monologue is like so what do you think
about that and she panics because she
didn't hear anything he's saying she
doesn't want to involve it now we've all
been there so don't listen to our bosses
she says
um so we are going to mandatory fun yeah
uh what he was saying yeah things he
could have been talking about like oh
they get their money from Kingpin or
something and because she's just
randomly kind of uh doesn't agree or
disagree she's agnostic at the end yeah
but he's kind of Blown Away that's
unprecedented unprecedented feel one way
or the other about what he just said but
we all here are perfect lip readers even
though we can't see the lips oh yeah oh
yeah yeah we can we can sense it we just
feel it we feel it so we're gonna what
we're gonna do for this
fun that is mandatory we're going to do
a little dubbing we're going to tell you
what he's saying what hallway's saying
exclusive yes that Jennifer didn't hear
yeah
um I I happen to have again I did some
kind of pretty extensive lip reading
yeah like posture intuiting uh so I have
a dub so maybe I'll I'll go first yeah
okay so we're gonna yeah we're gonna dub
over the clip John's gonna cue up the
clip here we are the um okay yes so
she's walking the arms oh um so as you
can see uh we have a lot of offices
there's a couple restrooms now you will
note that not all these restrooms are
great for number twos a few of them are
one only
um uh but uh you'll be given a map to
find the better number two restrooms and
eventually uh you'll come to understand
where you poop
hey this guy has his priorities and then
she says I'm agnostic and he's like wow
that's crazy you're agnostic you don't
care about where you poop some restrooms
pipe in music others are dead quiet you
don't want to be you don't want to be in
there you want to be smashing and
farting and whatever
yeah Brandon you mentioned that you had
a pretty strong Theory yeah what he's
saying I'm pretty sure I know what he's
talking about okay here and it's okay so
it's kind of crazy it's not blue no it's
not food related don't worry
um it goes on to say like as a
requirement of working here of course I
need to know everyone's undergarment
situation like these Two Fellas here
nothing this guy he's got those weird
Mormon stuff uh all those people over
there they use nothing she's
conservative at best uh and some of
these gentlemen you'll see in this
office here they have two pairs of boxes
they share between them passing them
around like wild animals it's kind of
crazy anyways what do you have
she's agnostic she's ass Gnostic
oh
very nice that was a general set down
um yeah nice that microphone's not on
um okay okay Angelica now you you
mentioned you had a pretty strong theory
about what he was saying yeah I do okay
great let's let's keep it up John uh so
Angelica to do a little dub
all right so welcome on in uh I actually
wanted to have this section converted
into like a gaming space but like they
didn't want that I don't know I guess
they wanted to work here or whatever so
that's where I wanted the Frogger
machine to go and over there
um so this one's Sarah Sarah she wanted
a big dog there but I didn't like that
so anyways uh moving on
um those guys they always just like to
stand up and laugh I don't know why they
do that anyways um so what's your take
on uh on Miss Pac-Man
oh agnostic do you think Miss Pac-Man's
better than regular Pac-Man yes yeah
whoa I I grew up with Miss Pac-Man a
little bit more but obviously I enjoy it
all and and supposedly there's like an
extended world of Pac-Man there's better
more recently there's better Lauren than
Miss Pac-Man yeah
um now yeah we probably have time for
one more quick dub Yeah you mentioned
that you had a pretty specific Theory
actually I um I met with the writers
right before this they gave me the
actual script so I'm just gonna do what
they what they okay all right
and um yeah so let me just show you
around the office over here a little
quick if you want to go to sandwich
brought up to you in about five minutes
uh you you can go talk to these uh these
jerks over here that guy we make him
watch new rock stars all day over here
oh this is Amanda she has RBF we just
pay her to me and mug everybody
um and uh now we're gonna be going
across this room oh this is the Warner
Brothers executive office
you know didn't have his audio up yeah
executive well we'll never know well I
will never know yeah all those pretty
strong options we'll find out maybe in
coming weeks they'll Replay that scene
and you'll get to hear some of these
audios
um real quick GSU Eagle uh one one seven
thank you for the Super Chat and you
know what he says let's end with some
haikus and everyone's best Emil Blonsky
impression I think that's a great idea
yeah
Russian born by British race right yeah
yeah yes okay is it called me oh my God
what that's offensive okay Brandon do
you want to lead options again these are
these are actual haikus written by the
Emile Blonsky character let me I gotta
get in my English character buy order of
the pinky [ __ ] blinds that's my
British okay I've made some mistakes
apologies to Harlem that one is on me
nice nice
very nice
um my British accent is not very good
and I get it I always try to get into it
and I don't know why but I think of uh
what's it like Pig million or oh sure
the rain in Spain falls mainly on the
floor she's like butterflies the poor
girl yeah that's what I'm talking about
yes yeah
I can't do it anyway okay thank you
um
and Emily is a monster Abomination is
death Amil will cheat death
yeah yeah but yeah he's coming very
heavy
um all right so uh this one from Emil
exclusive to uh break room is
I love my new chair
a broke my new chair with Fists
I love my new chair
somebody who's broken a chair live on
this show I can relate
here I've got I've got a good one again
this is uh I'm not gonna do the accent
because I'm terrible
I just made my voice softer okay don't
say yourself at home
okay
a little bit unluck with a little bit a
little bit um
My Fair Lady slaps okay that musical
holds up
no that there's like five great songs in
that movie okay anyways
right after right after don't worry baby
and uh don't worry darling don't do it
baby darling
I mean baby darling
baby Barbie darling lady okay all the
things I call my wife okay
um here we go
monsters never cry
soldiers follow all orders now
this Soldier cries oh these are deep
he's probably gonna read that to the
jury yeah
profound speaking of profound thank you
GSU Eagle 117. thank you everybody who
watched today
[Applause]
we really did it um we've got
She-Hulk not coming up
tonight but tomorrow night tomorrow
night on the show tomorrow we'll have
our predictions in chat you're killing
it you've been really uh following the
right people you're doing great up
points uh uh but we'll have all our
project predictions for the show for
episode three on the show tomorrow then
of course Thursday we'll be talking
about episode three yeah
and then not we're not too far out we're
getting rings of power yeah he's coming
out this weekend and then of course
early next week we'll have uh another
episode three of House of the Dragon
Brandon and Jessica been doing a great
job on uh talking dragons there
um lots of stuff going on and then we're
only a couple weeks out from Andor yeah
the show we refuse to talk about on this
we've had a big and or segment for the
end of the show today apologies to Andor
we don't have time to get to it right
that's right Sunday Sunday uh thank you
all so much for watching uh thank you
Tom Angelica Brandon for being here on
the show we'll be back live tomorrow on
another break room
bye